في هذا الملف نتوقف مع هذه التصريحات
لرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي في هذه الاخبار
العاجله رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو
يقول عشنا امس احد اصعب الايام منذ اندلاع
الحرب والجيش بدا تحقيقا في الكارثه
تتبعها سلسله تصريحات لنتنياهو ايضا يقول
فيها نبذل قصاره جهدنا للحفاظ على حياه
جنودنا ول توقف عن القتال حتى تحقيق النصر
المطلق اذا كانت هذه تصريحات رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي في ردود الفعل الرسميه
الاسرائيليه ايضا على مقتل 21 من ضباطه
وجنوده واصابه عشرات في معارك غزه قال
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوف جلنت ان هذه
الحرب ستحدد مستقبل اسرائيل للعقود
القادمه معتبرا سقوط الجنود الاسرائيليين
وصيه لتحقيق اهداف الحرب وقال الوزير
بمجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي بيني جانس انه
صباح صعب لشعب اسرائيل باكمله مع ما وصفها
بكارثه مقتل 21 عسكريا كما وصف وزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي يتس ال سموتريتش سقوط
هذا العدد من الجنود الاسرائيليين بانه
خبر مفجع متعهدا ب لا يذهب سقوطهم في غزه
سدن وفق تعبيره اما وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي مار بن كفير فقال ان المئات من
الجنود لم يسقطوا سودان ويجب الا تتوقف
الحرب كما دع بن كفير الى الاستمرار في
سحق العدو في غزه بكل قوه وفق تعبيره
بدوره قال زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه ياير
لابيد انه صباح صعب لا يطاق مع الاخبار
المريره عن مقتل
21 من الجنود
الاسرائيليين